l'association petits princes marmaille
organisé une vente d'oeuvres caritatives
au port de sainte suzanne
une journée afin de récolter des fonds
au profit des enfants atteints de cancer
et de leucémie
hospitalisé au chu de bellepierre
aujourd'hui carmen alliés qui a réuni
des amis et qui avec ses amis à peindre
des tableaux dabo sont en vente et
l'argent que nous allons obtenir que
l'association petits princes marmaille
va obtenir va nous aider à organiser
pour les enfants alors en dehors de
l'hôpital des journées des journées on
va dire des journées plaisir des
journées détente et puis aussi nous
organisons la fête de noël nous occupons
des anniversaires enfin voilà nous
essayons de de faire des choses
sympathiques qui coûtent toujours un
petit peu d'argent malgré tout et donc
cela ça va servir
ah ça trois artistes peintres ont
bénévolement réalisé six tableaux vendus
au profit de l'association des paysages
des maisons créoles des petites maisons
dans les eaux ont retracé un petit peu
la vie longtemps le calme la sérénité le
bonheur d'y vivre du temps lontan une
contribution à cette action solidaire
essentiel pour ces artistes
je veux quand même donné mon petit grain
le petit peu que je peux à l'association
ça me touche car en fait c'est
inexplicable c'est quelque chose qui me
vient vraiment plus profond du coeur et
j'espère pouvoir apporter mon aide
l'association ré aux autres aussi bien
sûr pour aude palant vergoz marraine de
l'association petits princes marmaille
il est important de réaliser de telles
actions est de permettre aux enfants et
aux familles d'oublier la maladie le
temps d'une journée
vous savez quand il s'agit d'enfants ou
de personnes âgées même à quatre pattes
je viens donc pour moi c'est important y
aura deux clowns
là on a eu des gens qui chantent et je
pense qu'ils vont être heureux puis je
crois que mon amie madame dindar à fait
à portée des petits cadeaux pour chaque
enfant malade et ça ça me touche
beaucoup
c'est un moment de bonheur pour ces
enfants qui pensent ça rien voilà donc
je suis contente
nassimah dindar était présente lors de
cette journée la présidente du
département et venues les bras remplis
de cadeaux pour apporter joie et bonheur
aux enfants et livré tout son soutien
aux bénévoles pour accompagner les
malades il n'y a pas que les médecins on
a aussi besoin d'accompagner les
familles
on a besoin de l'investissement de
bénévoles du monde associatif
on a besoin d'un maroni qui vient
raconter des histoires mettre son petit
grain celle là dedans en donner un peu
de joie d'un on a besoin de ce qu'ils
vont faire des tableaux pour que nous
puissions les vents et apporter une
petite contribution pour étaient tous
ces bénévoles des associations
un travail nexans grâce à l'argent
récolté lors de cette vente d'oeuvres
caritatives les enfants iront
prochainement visiter le musée stella
matutina et déjeuneront dans un
restaurant à la plage